Річка Нарва - природний кордон між Естонією та Росією.
Річка з’єднує і водночас розділяє
два міста. На лівому березі -
естонська Нарва, тобто Європейський Союз.
На правому - Івангород. І це вже Росія.
Десятки людей щодня перетинають цей міст.
Багато хто має родичів на іншому березі.
Але навіть щоб просто піти в гості до рідних,
завжди потрібна віза.
28-річний Роман мешкає на естонському боці.
Він належить до російськомовної меншини в Естонії.
Таких тут приблизно чверть населення країни.
- Я - бікультурна людина.
Естонська мова та естонська держава не такі чужі для мене
і Росія, в принципі, під боком, і я періодично до родичів їжджу.
Я маю родичів в Івангороді.
Тобто виходить, що я поєднав у собі дві культури.
Можна бути російськомовним і при цьому
асоціювати себе з Естонією.
Роман у цьому не бачить нічого дивного.
Його родина об’єднала в собі дві культури.
Вони навіть спілкуються паралельно обома мовами.
Його дружина Ліна - естонка і в родині відповідає за естонську мову,
а він говорить із дітьми російською.
- Росія для мене - це як етнічна батьківщина,
звідки приїхали мої батьки.
Але загалом для мене вона зараз сусідня держава,
в яку я можу поїхати, яка для мене
не те щоб закордон, але й не батьківщина.
А Естонія для мене - батьківщина.
Я тут народився, виріс, у мене тут сім’я, робота, друзі.
Роман та його родина - приклад успішної інтеграції.
Проте в Нарві з її на 90% російськомовним населенням
побутують і інші погляди.
Частина мешканців навідріз відмовляються
приймати естонську культуру й пишаються тим, що вони - росіяни.
Це переважно старші люди, які навряд чи колись змінять свою думку.
Один із них - 46-річний Сергій Середницький.
Він свідомо обрав російське громадянство.
- Я за національністю росіянин і, якщо ідентичність
визначати за національністю, звичайно, відчуваю себе росіянином.
Ще тут накладається, що з естонською мовою в мене не дуже добре,
тому що... це можна пояснити такими собі лінощами
- не найкращою рисою характеру.
А з іншого боку, коли треба було вчити мову
з 20 років, тоді в мене не було особливої мотивації,
бо все місто розмовляло російською.
Старшому поколінню російськомовних мешканців Естонії
часто докоряють тим, що вони не бажають інтегруватися.
Проте ця проблема стосується й молоді.
Одні діти ходять до школи з російською мовою навчання, інші - з естонською.
Директорка гімназії в Нарві, де викладають естонською,
сама належить до лише 5% городян, для яких це рідна мова.
Але вона вільно володіє і російською.
- Якщо, наприклад, російськомовна дівчина
вчиться в російськомовній гімназії,
мешкає в російськомовному місті, вчиться
в цьому ж місті і її оточують точнісінько такі ж люди,
тоді вона погано вивчить естонську мову і знатиме її тільки поверхово.
Артем Поляк каже, що інтеграцію слід починати з дитинства.
Сьогодні він запросив учнів російськомовної школи
з сусіднього міста на семінар в естонськомовну школу Нарви.
Вони розмірковують над тим, як їм краще
використовувати свій потенціал, зокрема поза їхнім
російськомовним культурним середовищем.
Адже їхня батьківщина - Естонія.
- У нас в Естонії зовсім нещодавно з'явився такий термін, як "естоноземельці".
Тобто це люди, які мешкають на території Естонії,
тому вони - естоноземельці.
Байдуже, яке в кого походження.
Одна зі школярок - 16-річна Ліза. Її тато дуже шкодує,
що не вивчив естонську мову. Дівчина впевнена, що
двомовність відчинить перед нею багато дверей.
- Професія, яку я хочу обрати, пов’язана саме з тим,
що я не можу жити на одному місці.
Я хочу стати льотчицею
і тому, мабуть, легше буде жити в Талліні, бо там одразу аеропорт.
Семінар може стати імпульсом для школярів.
Артем задоволений, адже він щиро вболіває за успіх проектів,
які допомагають об’єднати молодь в Естонії.
- Наша організація тісно спіпрацює з агентством,
яке естонською називається SANA.
Воно фінансує проект молодіжних зустрічей,
у якому беруть участь щонайменше
12 російськомовних підлітків і 12 естонськомовних.
Вони спільно протягом, скажімо, тижня
обговорюють якусь тему і таким чином інтегруються.
Такі проекти були б неможливими без допомоги Євросоюзу, наголошує він.
Із задоволенням розповідає молоді
про сенс виборів до Європарламенту, а також
про інші шанси, які дає їм Євросоюз.
Таких шансів не дуже вистачає молоді
на іншому боці ріки Нарва.
Багато з тих, хто мешкає в Івангороді,
з заздрістю дивляться в бік Нарви.
- Ну, в принципі, хочеться переїхати. Але зараз дитина ще росте,
поки ще в садочку тут, а надалі вже, може,
переїдемо, щоб в естонську школу пішов.
Там освіта краща і, в принципі, для подальшого розвитку
на роботу влаштуватися також в Європі все ж краще.
Багато молоді хоче поїхати з Івангорода
і перебратися або в Санкт-Петербург, або всього
на кількасот метрів західніше - в Естонію, а отже, і в Євросоюз.
Молодих людей російської периферії непокоїть
відсутність розвиненої інфраструктури та перспектив.
Із однолітками з Нарви їх зближує бажання чогось досягти в житті.
Але мешканці Івангорода мріють реалізуватися
поза межами рідного  міста, а молодь у Нарві -
зокрема і в себе вдома.
Але мета і тих, і інших - краще майбутнє для своїх дітей.
Що думає Роман: де його діти - Сандер і Лаура -
будуть щасливішими: в ЄС чи в Росії?
- Поки що це занадто віддалена перспектива.
Коли вони стануть дорослими, то самі вирішать,
чи залишатися тут.
Можливо, на той час ситуація тут докорінно зміниться
або вони вирішать поїхати кудись далі.
Це вже залежатиме від ситуації тут і від того,
як вони самі себе визначатимуть.
В одному Роман переконаний: перед його дітьми відкриті різні шляхи.
І він буде виховувати їх так, щоб і в їхніх грудях
билися два серця і щоб вони вважали це нормальним.